this is jaco podcast number 102 with
echo Charles and me Jocko Willing good
evening echo good evening and we are
rolling into some QA from the interwebs
sure so let's go right to it
Jocko is there ever a good time to use
an ultimatum mmm that's a great question
and I think the answers actually I think
what everyone thinks about the answer I
think it's pretty self-evident and I
think a lot of people will agree with it
okay so is there ever a good time to use
an ultimatum I think sometimes there is
but it's seldom it's actually very
seldom but when enough is truly enough
then you got to draw the line and you
got to hold the line right so you got to
make an old ultimatum one thing that is
extremely credible is that you should
never make an ultimatum that you won't
or can't keep yeah yeah right
let love you don't go off if you say it
do it yeah and what's interesting from a
job perspective so like in the workplace
perspective let's say up the chain of
command up the chain of command it's not
good right so so let's say you're my
boss and I coming into Echo I want a
raise I want to buy this Friday or I'm
out of here
right that's an ultimatum and that means
I'm trying to hold you hostage most
people do not like being held hostage
so my chances of actually supporting
what you're trying to make happen are
very small because I'm actually mad at
you yeah I don't want to support you oh
you're a big critical guy because you
press record and you made some videos
for me you know what I mean like it's
like that yeah but you're throwing an
ultimatum at me yeah oh that's where
we're happy we couldn't have a
conversation we couldn't come to an
agreement so you're gonna walk in to me
I'm the boss I just reversed roles here
walk into me I'm the boss you're gonna
say
Jaakko I wanna raise and I want it now
or I am out
here on Friday that's my ultimatum
mm-hmm what are you doing are you
building relationship with me no are you
giving any room to negotiate on the new
are you giving yourself any room to
maneuver no you're not you're not giving
yourself any room to maneuver so that
one generally doesn't work very well now
now if you have another job offer that
someone's put in front of you that's
legit and it's good and it's solid and
you come in to me and say hey jockle I
got another job offer they want an
answer by Friday here's what they're
gonna pay me I'm not this isn't a threat
I'm not trying to be a jerk I'm being
straight up with you but if you don't
give me what I want by Friday I'm gonna
have to leave and go cuz I gotta i can
improve my future yeah and I'd say hey
man that sounds like a great deal
working for them go right but that so
that's that's an ultimatum but it's a
rational one right and because you
actually have a backup and you actually
are trying to be straightforward with me
yeah so so that's an ultimatum but it's
it's like a logical one now down the
chain of command
people don't like ultimatums either for
instance you know echo if you don't have
this project done by Friday you're fired
so now I put a big old tomato on you and
you don't like that any more than the
Boston people don't like having
ultimatums put on so what really do if
you have to use ultimatums down the
chain of command and you should check
your leadership real real quick cuz
you've made some mistakes right people
don't understand the deadlines people
don't understand what did you want them
to do people don't understand why
they're doing what they're doing there's
all kinds of things that they don't
understand if you have to start throwing
ultimatums around as a boss so really if
you find yourself using ultimatums then
you you need to check your leadership
now that being said if you if I've
talked to you if I've coached you if
I've counseled you if I've done a
written statement on you and told you
exactly what it is that I need echo to
do and now we've we passed the point of
no return I go okay echo here's what I
asked you to do you didn't do it this is
the old tomato if you don't start make
three videos a week you are not gonna be
here anymore
mm-hm and you'd say you'd either say
okay well I'm gonna do it or screw Jocko
he's a jerk I'm out of here
either way I've moved forward because
you weren't doing it before and that's
sort I know that that example was yeah
kind of hits close to home
so ultimatums be very very careful make
sure if you're gonna use it it's got to
be real you've got to enforce it and
check yourself don't don't don't get
yourself in a position where you can't
maneuver anymore that's the biggest that
to me that's the biggest point yeah you
never want to take away your ability to
move maneuver you don't want to do that
yeah makes sense and it feels like you
know it's just how you kind of said it
to me well that first one where the tone
has like a lot to do with it yeah like
how you were like the you know you're
legitimate logical alternative right
right it seemed like it wasn't like the
first one the first two look give me
this or I'm out of here kind of thing
and then the second your second exactly
like hey you know what's going on yeah
it feels like if someone did that to me
either way up or down I feel like you
would still maintain the relationship
you know like let's say let's say it
worked out and it was like okay you know
whatever you got the raise or whatever
and if you sending out crazy tone or
whatever was that real fed up tone yeah
you're still like okay cool we worked it
out I got what I want but like but but
we know we've been thoroughly
yeah it's dinged and you don't want to
be dinging or relationships we want to
be building those things yeah and I
think a lot of times people like
building their relationship and then
they'll just move on like nothing but
meanwhile other persons I can know like
don't forget what you said to me and how
you said that last week time heals the
wounds but it doesn't remove the scars
slap shot all right next question ex
wish graduated high school crushed it
straight A's
boom help my classmates was kinda kind
and helpful and expected them to be mean
they put me down mocked me never loved
me in a room with 30 people I was always
alone inner voice tells me to go after
the past seek revenge keep looking at
their profiles profiles the con line
broke yeah
social media yeah yeah should I go now
he's got a series of questions here yeah
should I go after them and try to fix
the past either by revenge or else
should I should I remove them from
social media and leave the the Facebook
group should I attend the reunion
why have they even been in my life okay
so let's break those down number one
should I go after them and try to fix
the past either by revenge or something
else they answer that in my opinion is
no man who cares they're high school
kids move on get on with your life yeah
disagree agree agree okay that that one
to me is pretty straightforward
mmm-hmm don't worry about these humans I
actually had a couple conversations with
with my oldest daughters haven't had
this one with my son yet but my older
daughters which is hey look these people
that are around right now that you think
are so important in high school mmm
they're hot you know some of them might
be you might have some lifelong friends
from high school I get that but these
people that are not nice to you you
won't be thinking about them so I don't
I'm not sure how old this individual is
but he's got a couple more years before
he won't be thinking about these people
anymore so just get there earlier
question two should I remove them from
social media and leave this Facebook
group okay this is a little bit tricky
in my opinion first of all if you can if
you can stay if you can keep them on
social media but ignore them completely
just leave them alone just leave it in
just totally ignore them because when
you leave them or whatever you're kind
of aren't you kind of making this scene
yes okay I just want to make sure so you
don't make a scene well yeah like when
you unfriend them which yeah didn't you
and I have some stitches yes with you
yeah yeah oh okay so I know that I won't
wait who unfriended you my wife
yep okay so you did it well no no no I
didn't even know how to do it not but I
I figured it no I didn't so I didn't
ever have social media until two years
ago but all of a sudden I saw EKKO
friends with my wife and she's like
showing me something and she says and I
see EKKO
and I said why are you friends with
people that why you friends with people
that I know I'll click unfriend on that
and I didn't even know as a big deal I
just thought you know hey that means and
and then I didn't realize a big deal
it's a big one man yeah unfriended you
messed up I thought you did it purposely
knowing it's a big deal but not
understanding that it's even a bigger
deal then you know how are you like
unfriend him as a joke that was like it
was totally your personality at that oh
you thought I did that to you yeah like
as a joke like I'm frame you not to say
something to me like immediately or was
it that a month go by where I didn't
make a joke about it so so it is kind of
making a scene yeah if you if you
unfriend this person or you leave the
group then you're just creating a little
firestorm but I will say this if you
can't if you can't keep yourself from
checking on them yeah then you might
have to do that mm-hmm so try it for a
couple of weeks just I'm not looking at
them yeah let him go
just leave them if you can't do that
then delete them and leave the group or
whatever so number three should I attend
the reunion my answer to that is
negative don't why would you
these people are negative then they
bring back negative memories they didn't
treat you well they but why would you
you don't need to move on again key word
I think move on and then the last
question is why have they even been in
my life well I think just like anything
else bad that happens in life the things
that are bad that happened in life
can either teach you or break you
mmm and you got to decide what you want
them to do I vote that you you allowed
to teach you I ivote did you learn from
these people that you learn how to
forget about the past that you learn how
to ignore people that are negative that
you learn to control your vengeful ideas
and that you learn to move on into the
future where you're gonna meet better
people and better time should be at yeah
that's what I would recommend don't
worry about these people from the past
they're caught up in this weird world
yeah high school this is high school
right we'll caught up in high school
world more worried about high school
yeah get into the world
yeah right big time well I got I've had
one daughter that now graduated from
high school I had two kids in high
school right now yeah drama there's
drama but actually believe it or not
there hasn't been a lot of drama with my
kids yeah not a lot I school drama that
doesn't surprise me
yeah but but I see it it has happened oh
yeah and I remember the drama I'd say um
I guess I don't know it's been a long
time since high school for me personally
but yeah man I think that's life you
know I squeeze drama use a bunch of kids
not knowing nothing is there more drama
in high school than there is in life
maybe it's because it's stuck together
yeah you think your sleep depends on
your life
like you just consider a typical high
school versus my life yeah way more in
high school I mean your drama that's it
really yeah yeah they're all high school
although even this guy obviously you
know so it's gonna feel like way more
than it is for sure but you know when
you when you the the further you go
along in life the more you realize that
this means less these types of things
anyway when you consider it high school
is really just for learning sure you
learn like you know some things too you
know what I just thought is is what's
interesting about this is if you're
looking back on high school either with
fond memories or with negative memories
either way it's not a great thing
because
could be like uncle Rico from Napoleon
Dynamite right constantly living back
his high school football games yeah yeah
yeah and he's wishing he made that pass
and you don't I mean what a state
championship or whatever that's not good
mm-hmm right that you that means you're
stuck in high school you peaked in high
school yeah if you're looking back at
the negative things same thing yes and
who know move forward yeah in his
defense though obviously he just
graduated so he's life really is this
really you know new it's like you know
someone more stuffs gonna happen brother
you move on and get after it yeah fully
the social media thing now say this cuz
there's there's little levels of like
unfriending order you can unfollow
someone I'm assuming this is Facebook I
don't know you know there's so many you
could be talking about of the stuff but
on Facebook you can still remain remain
friends but just unfollow them so you
won't get all their stuff do they know
that I don't think so they're nuts I'm
sure many people have unfollowed me and
I don't know that I've never be alert or
whatever um I would leave the group
fully oh yeah you're giving me your
advice more than me because I don't
understand it as much as you do I guess
yeah I don't understand the Facebook
group thing yeah I mean depends how many
people seem like who's gonna make a
scene I don't like to make a scene yeah
so I'd be like well no I'm just gonna
ignore it yeah I don't think leaving the
group is a scene if it is I mean
obviously depends on how many people in
the group is less people in the group
the more of a scene it's gonna be or if
he's always boasting if he's the head of
the group or something like this then
yeah you know how in the past there was
a ticket schools I went to I went to
etiquette classes when I went to Austria
and it's cool in that's all the Florida
and they teach you which knife to use
yeah yeah yeah and all that stuff and
they teach you things for instance you
might not know this if you take a bite
of food and there's something in that
bite of food that you don't want to eat
a bone or whatever uh-huh the way to
properly get it out of your mouth is to
use your fork put it on the fork and put
it back down on the plate so like yeah
okay gotcha
they would say the same so that's the
type of thing yeah there should be a
class or we're going to a point where
people are getting to class on
social media etiquette yeah actually
that's not a bad idea you should teach
it all right let's move on I have bangs
on yeah yeah that's cool yeah move on
move on brother yeah move on let's move
on from that question there it is way
don't you know that's like that's like
you know that's we focused on social
media but that's just about everything
right anything that you're caught up in
yeah anything that you're caught up in
yeah and that's dragging you down just
move on yeah whether it's a girl whether
it's the job you should have had whether
it's the investment you should have made
whether it's the the house you didn't
buy that you should have all those
things yeah move on man it's gone move
on yeah it seems like high school is
this really common one you know like the
old classic story of the person who got
bullied in high school and then came
back down yeah you know like that kind
of stuff but yeah the more and this is
what it feels like to I don't know I'm
not everyone but the more you do for
yourself after I sure the less high
school is gonna mean first like this
isn't gonna and you know they say yes
uncle Rico man he he sell in Tupperware
yeah and it wasn't working out good for
him
yeah high school is still a big deal too
yeah yeah you know guys we were like
they always talk about high school
football what I just into and there's
guys like that for sure then you can
it's kind of an indicator you know that
oh you know you might not be doing much
now you know yeah so shit they're like
40 years something like that check I
next wish I'm thinking about starting
jiu-jitsu in my MMA gym but the
instructor is a brown belt should I go
train with him or look for a black belt
well if you're at an MMA gym they have
brown belt that's awesome I train with a
brown belt I think he's probably really
really good I think it's probably fight
oriented because it's in a fight to
fight gym sure which is good in my
opinion and you know the fact the matter
is and we've said this before brown belt
purple belt black belt there's good
teachers in all those blue belt mmm you
know borderline really you can learn
some good fundamentals from a solid blue
belt though agree
but and also there's some black belts
that are not good teachers and there's
some purple belts that are phenomenal
teachers so yeah go train yeah I think
that's pretty simple question yeah the
it depend on how you just said like some
some verbal belts are great teachers
away so that the belt usually for the
most part just indicates the the vast
like the knowledge you know so it's
given that they're a good teacher so
yeah if it's a brown belt shoot that's a
lot of knowledge and just given that
he's alright more better teacher that's
gonna be legit and there is actually
blue belt as well yeah I shouldn't said
that there's some blue belts that are
really good teachers yeah although it
does you know you get a purple belt
teacher wears the blue belt teacher and
they're good teachers both of them of
course you're gonna want the part
because he's gonna have more knowledge
the purple bones you know so you don't
blue belt in most cases yeah yeah it is
in most cases yeah but if you're just
starting growing you can pray you're
just gonna be like a sponge
yeah if someone you don't even know what
you you know what's interesting you
could probably barely tell if you're a
white belt and you roll with a purple
belt in a black belt you wouldn't go but
yes and all you know is you've got your
know yeah that's all you know you don't
know how easy it was for them because
it's the same level for both neither one
of those peoples trying hard against the
white belt yeah and yeah and if they
know how to teach like I said he's an
instructor he's the instructor yeah yeah
he's gonna be fine in fact that's way
more common I mean we're in San Diego
yeah even in San Diego though there's a
brown belt instructors for sure yeah and
they're good too yeah and especially if
you're just starting yeah man good do
that and yeah just like how you said
though sometimes the black belt
instructor he'll be good at rolling
he'll be good at Jiu Jitsu and he can
win tournaments but I can't really
instruct that good or they or you get
like situations where I mean I wouldn't
say it's super common but it's there for
sure is you know you're the the
expression curse of knowledge right it's
like you've been a black belt for so
long or anything right it's just so good
at something that you forget what it's
like to be a beginner yeah so you kind
of you know you might skip over some
details that are kind of critical if
you're a beginner you
you just kind of your subconscious just
assumes that this person knows a certain
amount of things you know you can get
that like that's I think a lot of times
what jams up but really been Dean juris
watching an Indian Noah role we were
doing some rounds of candy and Noah
tucked his foot underneath the far arm
on an arm walk from a crawl across I'd
like a regular arm lock and no was
talking his foot under there and Dean
says jeans do you know hey that's a
really good detail - who taught you that
mm-hmm you know I told him he was like I
taught him and nobody that that's
something that Dean taught me and I
don't know who taught Noah but it's just
that's the type of detail that you're
talking about where that is a small
thing you got to be in jiu-jitsu for all
you got to get a lot of other things
right before someone says hey when
you're armed locking someone on the far
side put your put your toes basically
underneath their arm to secure their
shoulder a little bit better yeah that's
that's deep yeah there's so there's
those kind of details there's another
thing where I had a finish for Dean or
Dean was teaching me an armlock finish
and I would try and I was try it know
what try it know would try it and it
would never work I tried it on him 50
times and finally one day he says hey
when you do that move put the pressure
here instead of here the next time I did
it to him worked you know what I mean
and then one little detail
yeah same thing happened the other day
with Andy I was going with Andy and we
were doing the arm walk escapes and he
said hey you're putting a pressure here
he showed me where I was putting the
pressure he said put it here don't look
hmm next time I did it to him he's like
that hurts so bad yeah yeah so it's
weird it's a little details that again
the better the instructor is the the
more details you're gonna get and most
well what's important about this is
until you are get to a certain level you
those details don't even mean anything
to you yeah cuz it you you can't worry
about where you're putting some little
detail on an armlock when you do that
how to do the arm be pretty damn good at
the arm lock before you start looking at
the little tiny details yeah
that's like that that was actually gonna
be part of the point where you get a
black belt super advanced level
instructor but he's not necessarily that
good at being a teacher he'll start
teaching those details and on stuff in a
fanzine ways whoa you just skipped over
the part to teach them how to do the
actual armbar but he's like kind of
subconsciously they'll be like he'll the
curse of knowledge says that it's kind
of just assumed this is good for their
Jitsu journey I used to say this when
when I'm teaching you a jiu-jitsu move
let's say there's ten things that you
have to do to make the jujitsu move work
I can teach you five of them mmm the
other five you have to figure out
because it's where you're putting your
weight and you're putting your balance
Dean might be able to teach you seven
hmm
maybe maybe if you take a different
class and II will teach you an eighth
one but there's things that you have to
figure out on your own on top of the
things that you can be shown yeah that's
why you gotta roll yeah big-time
you got a roll because that's the only
way you figure out if it actually works
or not and what a little adjustment you
have to make yeah yeah fully and
especially if you have a good instructor
they can see it too you know like you
you know when you drill something or
when you're doing the technique just
with your partner and stuff you're like
okay yeah good that's good technique in
the one that's moving and trying to
defend or whatever it's like I don't
know what I'm doing wrong it's not
working but and really the obvious
answer is yeah because he's not letting
you do it but you know someone like an
instructor can look and see like oh look
you're letting him do this or one or
whatever you're forgetting to do this
nonetheless yeah I I agree with you go
train with the brown belt guy yeah don't
train yeah but if you're not learning
nothing then you can make that
evaluation but the fact that he's a
brown belt yeah we learned a ton you'd
be learning a ton given that for sure
next question you talked about playing
the game quote-unquote to win but what
about people that play the game to win
for themselves
and how do I defeat them that's a good
good question and it hit me yeah when I
saw that question ooh that's a good
point and that's a good there's a very
important distinction there because I'm
always saying play the game yeah yeah
you gotta play the game you gotta you
gotta build the relationships with the
boss
you gotta learn what they like and you
gotta tow the party line you gotta do
the little things you gotta support the
corporate headquarters or the boss or
the man right or whatever entity is up
in that ivory tower I want you to play
the game get them on your side and the
reason I say to do those things is that
so you can get more control so that
people ask your opinion so that you get
listened to so that perhaps you get
promoted which is good but the reason
you're doing all those things the reason
that you're playing the game is to help
your team accomplish the mission that's
what you are trying to do is to help
your team accomplish the mission now the
the other side of that is what this
question is about people that are
playing the game for personal gain they
they play the game so that they can get
listened to so they can drive their
personal agenda so they so they can get
promoted and they want to get promoted
so they can abuse their power and maybe
that abuse of power is just is just
working less maybe it's making other
people do the crap jobs whatever that
whatever the case may be but they've got
an agenda they're gonna try and get
promoted so they can take care of
themselves and that is not why I tell
you to play the game and that's not why
I played the game and I definitely
played the game and I played to win but
I played because I wanted my squad or my
platoon or my task unit or my training
command to be able to better accomplish
our mission that's when I played the
game now there is a secondary benefit of
playing the game
and that is that you could possibly get
promoted earlier you could get praise
from the boss that looks good on your
record and all those things can happen
when you're playing the game but that's
just like collateral sort of fringe
benefits but that's not why you're
playing the game you play the game to
help the team win
and when the team wins you win which
also makes the team win again so it's
like a positive cycle because you start
developing the good reputation now you
get more leeway from the boss in a more
lean way you get from the boss the more
you have the ability to make maneuvers
on the battlefield the more you can
maneuver on the battlefield the more
offensive you could be the more
offensive you could be the more you win
and then you get more ability to move
more because your boss is giving you
even more room to maneuver so it's a
it's a cycle it's a good positive cycle
now when you have someone that's on the
team that's playing the game for
themselves first of all no one likes
that person right and everyone can see
that person no one likes them and
there's believe me the military the
military has unbelievable people that
play the game for the best possible
reasons to help their platoon and help
the mission and help succeed there's
also plenty of people in the military
and in every every different line of
work
there's plenty of people that play the
game because they want to they want to
they want are looking out for themselves
looking out from number one right isn't
that the expression they're looking out
for number one there's plenty of people
and I dealt with people like that all
the time
and what did I do I used to tune my
advantage and I'll tell you what I would
get in their head and what I would do is
I would make them think that the best
way for them to win for themselves
personally was for the team to win I
would get that into their head because
that's all a lot of times they missed
that point they're looking out for
themselves they're not worried about the
team and I would get them thinking that
they're gonna look the best if the team
wins hey if you really want to look good
the best way you can get promoted is if
we look good you know if the team does
great if you get us the gear we want the
equipment we want their training that we
need that's the best way you're gonna
look awesome because we're gonna succeed
more and that's gonna make you look good
mmm
and I'm of course I'm gonna be more
tactful
I'm not saying it like that but I'm
saying it right don't get me getting
that get the messaging is they're gonna
be saying things hey you know our boss
doesn't like our boss doesn't like
leaders that complain right you know
until the boss he doesn't like
complainers you know I mean little
little things like that right okay the
boss the boss likes to hear the truth
about stuff he wants to know what you
know what I mean little things like that
and you know here's the thing that
person that person might get the
promotion because what you've done is
you've helped them act correctly
actually and there's a chance a decent
chance a good chance even that they
carry that forward they realize that hey
the best way to play the game is to help
the team and the best way to look good
is to help deads is to make the team
good and succeed at the mission and it's
really well you know one of the classic
cases then we'll get into ownership a
little bit but if something goes wrong
right the person that's looking out for
themselves blames everyone else mmm and
and so that's a challenge right because
once you start blaming once that boss
starts blaming everyone then the whole
team starts blaming each other so how do
you fix that
well we've talked abouts a million times
you know you step up and say hey you
know a boss is my fault hmm boss that's
right it's your fault and there's a
there's a good chance that they
recognize how positive that is hmm and
it may take a while and it may never
happen because some people are just
savages right some people are just
complete they only care about themselves
they only care about the next promotion
and getting the next award and getting
the next bit of recognition there's
people like that there's they're
horrible they're horrible they exist but
they're pretty small most people if they
see hey this this is working for this
guy it can work for me too and that
starts to spread and the other thing
that happens I think is if someone's a
just a flagrant self promoter mm-hmm
that you might get them one promotion
because
you were there to kind of make them look
good but the next time around they're
gonna get seen they're gonna get found
out they're gonna people are gonna
realize what kind of person they are and
that's that's where it catches up with
them so you keep playing the game you
keep you keep working hard don't worry
about them and actually do your best to
help them out the person that's like
self-promoting do your best to help them
out if they're the boss make them look
good I always want to make my boss look
good yeah yeah it's gonna help you in
the long run yeah it hurts sometimes
yeah it's hard to do sometimes yeah our
ego gets in the way sometimes can't put
that ego in check because what's more
important because if you're my boss echo
and you're doing this just to make
yourself look good if I then undermine
you well and now we don't accomplish the
mission as well I'm actually a bad
person because I didn't do my best to
accomplish the mission mmm right we
didn't look good yeah I'm not worried
about how we look but we failed in our
mission oh we didn't do our mission to
the best of our ability so now I'm not
gonna let that happen you want to look
great cool I want to make you look great
because I want to look great doing our
mission because that's what's important
to me yeah and if some of the collateral
damage of that is that you look great
even though you're a jerk and I get you
promoted that's okay because eventually
you're gonna get found out or you're
gonna learn to be a better person and to
support the team and that's how you got
promoted and you're gonna realize that
you'll become a good leader yeah yeah I
agree with that
when well like I always have where
people can see that too you know they
can see yeah you know like if your boss
is like a self-promoter or whatever and
you have it in your head I understand I
understand this because I've been in a
situation where I'm like shoot I kind of
feel inside like I don't want to like
make an effort to make them look good
kind of thing because it's like he
doesn't deserve it
anything and what like what I'm gonna
make him look good and now everyone's
gonna think that he looks good kinda
thing but then when you really think
about it another not yeah you're right
and the same goes for you like if you if
you're like too you know if you're just
focusing on the positive stuff you know
you know how like your
you know if you don't have anything nice
to say don't say it at all if you're
really doing that like people noticed
that too like man that guy is like
really positive focus you know kind of
thing like people see it this doesn't
mean you're just mr. positive sugarcoat
and everything and no it's not what I'm
talking about that but you are not
focusing on the negative instead of
saying oh we're horrible at this
you say you know what we got some
deficiencies here here's what I'm gonna
do to fix them yeah yeah how simple is
that get better yeah the point is people
they see they see don't think that you
know like you're gonna help you know
make this guy look good in they're just
good they're gonna not see it and
they're just gonna fall for the trick or
science Bradley see that most of the
time yes that example that you said
about playing to their ego or whatever
where you're like hey you know you're
gonna look really good if so you ever
seen the movie Moana I saw three minutes
on it
ah see there you go she does excel the
guy the main guy's name the demigod the
name is Molly I'm played by the rock by
the way don't eat onsen great movie by
the way um she does him like that she's
like hey let's they got to go do this
mission you know to restore the heart
you know whatever it's long story but
and he's like you know whatever
reluctant and he's like she's like hey
you'll be a hero again and he's like I'm
already a hero just like Wow no not for
a while you know you haven't done
anything lately but if you do this and
you'll be the hero to everyone and yeah
and of course he does it of course be a
man it's good to get a quick example it
works there is proof on Mahna Mahna next
gesture I have to say that in a very
competitive environment extreme
ownership can be used by your enemies or
the people that want your position when
you take ownership over all faults of
your team members you guys become you
guys become better and get healthier a
healthier attitude but that takes time
so until your team improves and start to
get better results your opponents will
take those tens of it was my fault and
present
to your boss as proof that yeah this guy
is not good or at least not confident
enough and looks weak it's not my case
for me it worked great but I've seen it
happening to few colleagues who just
didn't have good team members and they
took their extreme ownership for
weakness and just took advantage of that
okay so what we've got here is what he's
saying is extreme ownership if you're
taking extreme ownership of things your
enemies can actually take advantage of
that and in this guy's case right like
in that like in the earlier Steve yeah
and he said well actually he says that
for him it's worked great but that he's
seen some of his compadres who have
started to take ownership and there
they've got weak team and the team what
does he say here what's the words he
uses they didn't have good team members
and they took their extreme ownership
for weakness and took advantage of it
okay so first of all out of the gate if
you have weak or bad team members that
is the first thing the leader needs to
take ownership of right if you have
truly weak and bad team members then you
need to either train them or coach them
or get rid of them that that's the first
thing mmm so if you've got backstabbing
bad team members that are looking to
call you down as the leader you got a
problem with those people then you need
to fix that problem number one mmm-hmm
so let's just start with that number two
and this is this is there's two to kind
of parts of this there's an insecurity a
level of insecurity and there's a level
of or a a matter of perception the
insecurity is the thing that says if I
say this is my fault and everyone up and
down the chain of command is gonna say
fire him fire him it's his fault but I
want you to think about how that's
actually perceived if what you do is
let's take the other example is what you
do is you blame everyone else if that's
your attitude if your attitude is it
wasn't my fault it was his fault it was
her fault it was their fault it was not
me I'm just a purse
in charge not me think about that
statement it's not my fault it's it's my
team's fault I'm just the person in
charge it's not my fault
think about that whenever you're placing
blame if you're a leader and you're
placing blame on your team what you're
saying is hey it's not my fault
it's my team's fault I'm just the leader
here hmm I'm not the one out there in
the field doing the work I'm not the one
that's making those decisions I'm not
the one that's I'm not the one that's
you know interacting with customers I'm
not the one that's doing that so this
isn't my fault it's my team's fault well
meanwhile guess who's in charge of the
team you are so the minute that you
start saying it wasn't my fault mr.
Farley everyone else's fault that if you
think about how you look to your boss
it's laughable you look like an idiot
you don't look like a good leader so
don't fall for it and you know what I'm
actually not saying that you'll never
get fired if you take ownership because
you know what if you do something that's
really bad there's absolutely a chance
you get fired if you do something that
cost a bunch of money or was immoral or
illegal or you've covered something up
and/or your team covered something up or
you did something that was truly wrong
then you take ownership of it yeah you
might still get fired you know what that
happens in the Navy and the Navy if your
ship runs aground or like lately there's
been some collisions on these ships and
all I think life and I might talk about
those at some point on the podcast but
the captain of the ship is done it
doesn't matter if you was on the ship or
not he could because just because the
ships at sea the captain might have had
to flown to another ship to talk to the
Admiral if his ship crashes he's done
doesn't matter if he's there or not he's
responsible for the training he's
responsible for the actions he's
responsible for everything that's
happened on that ship and he's getting
fired and he and also if he did do
something wrong yeah he takes ownership
of it doesn't matter he's getting fired
so I'm not saying you're never gonna get
fired but generally generally and this
is when I say generally this is the vast
majority of the time
this is 99% of the time if you take
ownership you don't look like a weak
boss you look like a strong boss that is
taking ownership of problems it is gonna
get the problem solved I say this over
and over again mm-hmm and as always you
don't just have to own the problems you
have to own the solutions to the
problems too so this is the situation
here you got this guy people the if
you're in charge of a bad team and
you're taking ownership the bad team is
what you have to fix you have to fix it
you have to train them you have to Kurt
you have to coach them you have to
mentor them you have to do all those
things and if you can't get them to get
on board with the program then you've
got to get rid of them
or get rid of that one or two bad people
that are causing the infraction and
causing that cancer to spread and get
rid of them set the example promote
somebody that's hungry and young and
wants to get after it so you've got to
take ownership of the team the problems
the weak people on the team you got to
take ownership of the solutions and get
them solved it seems like and I kind of
noticed this from the beginning go that
when you take I was gonna cut you off
with I have talked about this before
sometimes people say they think if they
say I'll take ownership with this then
the problems didn't it's like there have
been they're safe
that's exactly okay yeah yeah yeah that
is not the case yeah just because you
say this is my fault it's my fault I'm
taking ownership of this done that
doesn't mean the problem is solved
there's a problem yeah do you have to
say yes there's a problem here I'm
taking ownership if it's my fault
because I'm in charge and this is what
we're gonna do to fix it and then you
have to actually go and fix it there's
the part right there yeah that's seen as
if you come to me
12 times you say hey boy we didn't get
the podcast out because I forgot to hit
record hey that's my bust that's my boss
okay
will they hate from now on here's one
we're due I'm gonna make sure that we
have this things in place and I hooked
up a light and it's gonna you know the
thing isn't recording the studio is
gonna go dark I don't know if you
remember this cuz this might be just the
way you are but when we went to remember
now
where do we go we went like last trip we
went on we're driving we went to Oh
Charlie plum yeah I'm pretty sure it's
really yes and we were looking for I
can't remember what we're looking for
either the hotel or the place or
wherever a steak house was good so we're
going and I was kind of navigating and
you were kind of navigating kind of
trying to help not trying to help but
you were kind of navigating but kind of
not
mmm it really seemed like to me anyway
you were like okay I'll let you kind of
navigate and we we took her own turn
whatever you know we're on track or
whatever and I was like okay I gotta
take extreme ownership right now because
like right now is like the perfect time
to take extreme like or should I say the
worst time not to take extreme moment so
I'm like oh that's my bad guy coming in
you know I'm do this kind of thing but
at the same time you like really
aggressively took ownership like you're
almost to the point where at first I was
like are you joking
but you weren't joking seriously you
were like take take the next turn right
here and then we come close to it you'd
be like this turn right here
yes turned off you were not letting me
you know make it was taking it but which
is funny though but it is a good example
because not only I mean in your mind you
you put forward the more important part
you were like okay I'm gonna take it's
like your actions said that it's your
fault and but you're the solutions that
that you had even though they're really
extreme or whatever like that was the
part that you were in a jerk about it
no no just okay all right you know what
here's Daniel next turn is gonna be 0.5
miles here it's coming up on the right
yeah all right right hand turn right
yeah yeah yeah what is that's how that's
how we navigate oh it's actually good I
mean it's really squared away yeah
you're in a convoy of military vehicles
yeah it's awesome
and you know it's bad really on my part
is that at first I thought you're joking
like patronizing me you know yeah no I'm
don't do that but that's really kind of
my ego you know as if this is say like
duh I you said the next term this is the
neck sir
I can figure that out you know I'm smart
enough to figure that out kind of thing
but if I'm like okay this is the system
and you know chuckles gonna you know
tell me and he's gonna be detailed about
it and make absolutely sure we don't
miss the turn kind of thing then you're
right dang that's a good way to navigate
you know mm-hmm but two people gotta be
on board but nonetheless I think you had
the solution you know so goes back to it
like it seems like back to this question
um your enemies could take advantage
early on right as its as the extreme
ownership culture is trying to take hold
kind of that's what it kind of get from
even early on that's what I think even
early even early on you don't look like
an idiot
you actually look squared away because
you go here off the problems that we're
having yeah that I've identified here's
what we're gonna do to fix them yeah no
one knows where we're driving right now
you're kind of half driving and half
paying attention I'm over here talking
or doing whatever guess what we made a
mistake it's not gonna happen again I
got this Hey Yeah right turn coming up
five hundred meters right turn getting
the left-hand Lane prepare to go you
know what I mean that's how we solved
the problem and for to think in the
beginning you know you get there you say
hey here's the problem here's what we
need to fix it yeah it's not hey
everything's my fault that's not a dream
ownership isn't hey everything's my
fault everything's my fault and how can
you just leave me alone no you actually
have to take ownership of the problems
but hey you know what just like
jiu-jitsu you got to see you move a
bunch of different times a bunch of
different ways yeah
bunch of different ways before you start
to truly understand it yeah that's with
everything do you ever do you ever hear
yourself make an excuse no not anymore I
know like you know like how you say
excuses coming a mile away and here's
the thing you have them in your head
excuses complaining um complaining about
like how you feel you know like when
there's something to be done I'm not
saying you know in every single case but
when there's something to be done be
like I'm tired of doing this I don't
know what
that was just a random example but man I
can see that stuff coming a mile away
yeah it's definitely something that you
get used to and you get good at yeah
right you get good at you're good at
saying you get good at not saying well
you know one of my assistant platoon
commanders mmm who's an awesome guy
and he had this thing if he was gonna
disagree with me he would say the word
well meaning you know well let's think
but but he had a funny way of saying it
yeah yeah he would say well like that
and so I'd say hey we you know how you
gonna do this and he'd you know come up
with his plan and and I'd say hey what
about this on the plan you might want to
come in from the north and set from the
West and he'd go well and then I'd say
after a while I that became a code word
for you're about to get you yeah well
but he use it told he's an awesome guy
Jack next question
Jaco have head discipline equals freedom
audio on repeat since its release and I
love it question if our greatest
strength is our greatest weakness then
how is discipline which is obviously
your strength your greatest weakness
first of all I don't even know what I
don't know if discipline would be my
greatest strength I don't know I mean
I'm a discipline person yeah no doubt
but I think I think that I think that
one of the things that people would find
interesting is that I'm not overly
orderly mmm-hmm so if you think about
those like psychological characteristics
one of them is extreme orderliness which
normally goes hand-in-hand with highly
disciplined people you know those people
that are
they're just ultra highly disciplined
but they have to have everything their
OCD your OCD orderly right and I I'm not
like them about a lot of things I am
about some things but like it's pretty
funny actually my floor in my garage
mm-hmm where I workout isn't is not
clean right it's got salt stains on it
from sweat and it's dirty right and
occasional get someone saying you should
clean that floor or a man you should
clean that pool man that's nasty
but it's totally functional right yeah
and my point is that I I don't I don't
freak out about it it's functional it
doesn't bother me at all that it's not
perfectly orderly this also means that I
don't mind when things don't go as
planned right so a lot of times you get
people that are a high end of
disciplined yeah they're - they're too
far they're not balanced so now when
things don't go the way that their that
they've planned things to go they start
to lose it a little bit they can't deal
with it they want they want to have
everything in order all the time and
I'll tell you that's not the way life
works that's certainly not the way
combat works but that's not the way life
works and I don't really mind that I
don't mind chaos so I would say probably
if if you look at discipline as a
strength I don't think I think that
would be generally considered the
weaknesses of being hyper disciplined is
that you you can't stand when things are
not in order
yeah you can't stand like I missed a
workout this is you know you freak out
completely like you know okay I don't
like missing a workout but I don't lose
my mind go for it yeah now all that
being said I would say that I am a very
much a creature of habit and I do like
to do the same things over and over
again I don't like to travel even though
I have to travel a little time on a
lecture I'd rather stay home I pretty
much eat the same food all the time and
go to the same three or four restaurants
the time yeah right I like to follow
routine as much as I can you know it's
even in jujitsu I do the same basic
movements all the time I have the same
you know I've talked about like a funnel
like everywhere that you go with me it's
gonna lead to what I want you to be
because I'm gonna use those same moves I
surf the same spot all the time so I
guess I guess for me the way that
discipline is weakness or whatever for
me is that it may I think I'm I could be
fairly boring and predictable yeah for
other people yeah yeah you know yeah hey
you want to go try this thing at my home
no not really
yeah don't really want to I think you're
right about that though yeah cuz I'm the
same thing even are you same way exact
same way as well like I'm not highly
disciplined echo charm well I'm not
highly this one I mean but like the same
stuff like over and over again
the most funny I could I don't even like
new movies like oh you know what well I
I haven't had time to watch movies for a
long time yeah but but when I used to
watch movies to be okay I'm gonna watch
Big Lebowski again yeah yeah well I have
that kind too I think
but Big Lebowski I can't move either
okay so movies are different I'm not
going a whole thing about this but this
there's two types of different two types
of movies in this situation there's
movies that are like awesome in good
storyline maybe a great reveal at the
end or twist or whatever and it's like
good good story and then there's like
the type of movie that's just a series
of good parts where the story doesn't
really matter that much sometimes good
sometimes a jump but it's less about
that's more about this like the good
parts it's like oh there's part in this
well that's how the Big Lebowski is like
it's just a series of really good parts
yeah and it's awesome yeah yeah that's
what I mean I think they're both awesome
but the one with that had what was the
other one just the storylines awesome
okay you know like um I can't think top
my head but Big Lebowski is one of those
lot you like Napoleon Dynamite yeah yeah
like that's another one it's just a
bunch of good parts who cares about what
happens within in fact you probably
forget really I mean
what happens for the storyline you don't
really care but you'll watch it over and
over because all the parts are funny or
good or whatever and then like Point
Break for example I know we talked about
the first yeah yeah that's a good that's
a series of great parts like that's
certainly more the scary part the
behemoth at all the part they're just
really fun I mean sure the story is good
it's who it's fine we'll say that but
that's not the point the point is like
you know anyway Jack back to the point
though is oh when we're talking about
like being repetitive like liking the
same yeah boring being boring I'm boring
yeah cuz I okay so I'm like that right
where I eat a lot of sushi all the time
and there's a sushi restaurant within
walking distance on my house like it's
blackboard line drive but I go there
like not as much now probably go like
maybe three times a week now but there
is a point where I was going five to six
pieces week four and there's always more
than one so of course they just love ask
me and my brother goes to so yeah they
just love me in there cuz I go again
again we're just probably responsible
for a significant portion of their
revenue my wife she's not like that
oh she likes a different answer saying
yeah it's like variety and whatever and
so my wife will say you know let's say
we're gonna go out for dinner yeah let's
try something different
yeah I said okay tell me where yeah yeah
so we just go to old same things yeah
yeah say at least you have a few like
different yeah yeah I've I to and
they're both sushi places hmm
so it's like and it goes for like what
we do to during the weekend it's like
really repetitive yeah my wife uses the
word Groundhog Day planning like a lot
to speaking of great movies another one
great parts a bunch of great parts but
really who cares at the end you know
like the story what's that what's that
movie really about that what's the story
about that movie you don't know yeah I
totally know I've seen it look fun like
what you gotta be nice to the girl so
the ground all day stops like I don't
know what them yeah yeah it doesn't
makes it like that but it's a good movie
anyway so that was the point of moving
but but yeah so there my point is with
this is that yeah you will be boring
because my wife thinks I'm born in that
way or it's like it's just the same
same old every single time I'm like rile
up the stable thing I want to go on to
this all-inclusive finger whatever maybe
this is like way better you know and
yeah so yeah I think you're right I
think that money but so if you think
discipline isn't your biggest strength
what is what do you think your biggest
strength is oh I don't know I don't
think I have any big stress you know
what I think it is I think it it's
arguable maybe discipline yeah maybe
maybe not but Mallett essentially
balance you know man you're imbalanced
nope you're pretty balanced yep you know
I think it is well you told it to me -
oh you're durable Oh in terms of
physical I think even mental - though
that's the thing like you're you're like
a durable part you know how like people
like you you've told me stories I'm
going to them but you told me stories
about someone who made like huge
mistakes you know with you and you like
handle it and it doesn't seem like it
like bothers you you know like that can
stuff stuff that like ya know I do well
and you know it to me I guess that's
that's balance to me
yeah but to me balances I don't I don't
it's it's it's also boring alright
because I don't go far and wonder in the
other direction I don't get extreme
about this or extreme about that I just
I I think that's what has been good for
me yeah was I never freaked out about
stuff next question what's your biggest
strength my biggest yeah I'll tell you
what I think yours biggest ranked this
one you're humble you're super humble
yeah just the other day you were telling
me you were the most humble guy yeah me
I had her I had one of the most
egotistical persons that I've ever known
like I am not kidding about this
straight up tell me I have no ego I mean
it was it was like
it was completely insane you know I
couldn't believe that that this
individual was saying it now let's just
think of myself man that's crazy
Eagle is here's the thing I don't know
who you're talking about specifically
but I will say this we're obviously a
was it
oh I don't and this may even go along
with the idea that you think that I'm
humble it's like I don't even know if if
I'm humble or not because I know before
I wasn't humble before at all I love the
world like revolved around magna not
necessarily like bad way but just just
just how yeah it's kind of like if I had
certain feelings like they were just
more important than what was kind of
going on and it wasn't like necessarily
like like walking you know like a dick
or nothing like that
it was just that's kind of how I felt or
whatever and um you know complete
immaturity but at the same time when you
when you kind of pointed out that
humility is like a super important thing
I was like okay how can i how can i I
mean okay I'm gonna assume that's true
because you know what you're talking
about so what does that even mean and
then what I realized is a big like a way
to example if I humility is to I don't
know the ability to learn things from
someone who might not necessarily be an
expert for example you know like I think
you can learn stuff from a kid from a
blue belt yeah yeah yeah so from a white
belt yeah
so that kind of stuff but someone with
it would be like hey I'm a black belt
for sure what do you have to say to me
you know do you know that concept that I
did well interestingly in jujitsu you
could take it to the extreme of where
there was times where people thought you
can't learn anything from wrestlers you
can't learn anything from judo you can't
learn anything from ssam boat you know
that's that's that's crazy talk yeah you
know and and the good jujitsu players
take something from wrestling and take
something from do to take a punch from
wrestling a bunch of get a bunch from
samba well but and then create their own
stuff and watch on YouTube somebody that
does other stuff from a different
Academy yeah a different school yeah so
it's almost like this two different
types of humility where you know how
like someone who's really outwardly like
um you actually you add this example
we're like Conor McGregor for example
where I would like to hear him talk and
stuff like that you'd be like oh this
guy has a huge ego or whatever there's
no humble there's no humility with him
whatever but like he's learning all this
stuff from like people you bros I'm
training hall or yeah because he knows
he's humble yeah so what is that you
know like is there two kinds of
humbleness humility I think they're kind
of look and even if we were to look at
it there's some level of showmanship
with Conor right there's some way of
selling fights with Conor but even at
the same time like let's say that
because there's such thing as people
probably pretty common that people are
legitimately like into themselves in
that way collection Gabrielle we're
gonna have coach cabin on this podcast
at some point yeah yeah cuz I've gone
back and forth with him on social media
yeah yeah that'd be awesome yeah but but
but you can answer that question yeah
yeah yeah in general or but well about
Conor yeah about Conor heals Conor
protein anybody but you get people who
are legitimately cocky outwardly you
know kind of like but but at the same
time they can learn from they have the
humility to learn you know everyone kind
of thing yeah and you know what it is
almost even it might not even be
necessarily specifically being able to
learn from everyone it's more about what
you said a long time ago it's it's like
admitting to yourself that you don't
know everything yes and you don't
necessarily know more than everyone at
every single time it's like you have to
be humble enough to know that you don't
know everything so listen up kind of
that is the type of thing where even so
I will catch myself and I I used to
catch myself doing that let's say once a
day and then and then it was once a week
and it's once a month and and and and
it's pretty it's less now but sometimes
I'll catch myself listening to someone
mm-hmm and I'll catch myself thinking
how this guy does nobody sorry yeah you
know what I mean as soon as I hear
myself say wait a second take a
different perspective yeah because you
what can you not not this guy doesn't
know anything it's what can you learn
from this person yes the question yeah
yeah what can you learn from you can
learn something from him even if he's a
white belt even if he is inexperienced
even if he seems completely
arrogant crazy yeah even if you're
learning how not to act yeah that's
better than just saying oh this person
oh not gonna listen this person I've got
nothing to learn no you know I do so I
it's interesting as we talked about how
you make excuses you personally make
excuses less now I personally make
excuses I might be a little ahead of you
on that because I figured that out maybe
a little bit earlier and I'm older than
you
but it's you know I used to probably
make excuses once once a day yeah and
then once every three days and then once
a week that comes in plenty for the many
forms to the home making excuses because
it does necessarily only mean making
excuses to others it's like - so for
sure for sure that's the primary yeah
that's the primary the easy one to
overcome is making excuses to other
people the hard one to overcome is
making excuses to yourself yeah that's
the hard one overcome because it hurts
more yeah because of the minute you say
well you know I didn't get the thing I
wanted because of these external
external forces the minute that you
start saying that is the minute that you
stop working hard for that thing yeah
maneuvering for that thing or adjusting
for that thing or getting up early and
chasing that thing down it becomes an
excuse an excuse it becomes an excuse
like meaning for sure you just excused
yourself you did you just excuse
yourself from that work up oh yeah but
how would say back to the humility thing
and I don't know I'm just listening to
you at this point where maybe I am up
because I've always had had at least a
little bit of that where I'd be like
maybe this person right now even though
I hate what they're saying to me what
like they could be right they could be
right about me right now
and I think always had that I think
that's why you know some people they
just you talk to me no more whatever and
you're like the chance of this person
changing how they are is very low most
like most people right most people that
say my experience too but like yeah
something is a really big or something
really small has to happen over and over
know like it's a different impression
but I would say legitimately and I'm
trying to look at it as like honestly as
possible where me ten years ago is like
like if let's say I know someone new
someone ten years ago and I haven't seen
them or heard from him or whatever in
ten years and they like hung out with me
for a week they would be blown away
they'd be like you're just way different
you like a whole different but that's
the same with me I mean so so this is
funny there's a bar in San Diego sure
that I used to go to when I was back in
the teams and the course when I was yes
and I was a wild yeah I was a wild yeah
and there was a guy that was a DJ there
sure and I didn't even know and didn't
recognize I was usually not in a state
to even be paying attention to those
kind of things anyways to make a long
story short I decided I was gonna put in
an officer package and I put together
the package and I went into the
administrative office at seal team one
and I talked to the chief that was in
there and I said hey how you doing chief
you know I'm putting in this package and
I was just wanting you to take a look at
it you know if there's anything you see
I should add and he looked at me he goes
I hear put in a package huh and I said
yeah and he goes oh that's I wouldn't
expect that for it surprised and I was
kind of why not he goes well he was you
know I'm the I'm the DJ on this bar on
on these nights and I've been now for
you know five years and I said I was not
aware of that and you know in his mind
he was thinking that's what he knew me
as he didn't really know me because he's
in the admin office he wouldn't really
know me from anything else and that was
a little bit of a wake-up call but that
that so my point is I wanted not I
should never come off as a saint for
sure for sure not at all and even you
know to this day still working still
trying to figure things out but but
definitely back in the day I was an
idiot I had fun
I had fun but I was did a lot of dumb
stuff yeah but you're I mean in in you
know I I believe you 100% where you were
probably a certain way back then
and whatever it fit it was fun it was
all this or whatever and but you
legitimately changed a bunch or a big
part of fundamentally who you are
with being open to like critiquing
criticism and learn in whatever and I
think yeah I think the biggest thing is
I had open eyes you know what I mean and
as I moved into leadership position I
saw I saw how other people perceived me
and I saw the importance of leadership
and yeah I mean you just you just have
to change and that's something that as a
leader you you see this all the time
what got you here isn't necessarily
what's gonna get you there right and so
if you have leaders that if they were
aggressive yelling cowboy when they were
out in the field that's great but when
you can't you you have to you don't have
to stop that but you have to put some
rains on it you have to you have to rein
it in a little bit the more senior you
get the more you become accountable to
aboard the more you become accountable
to being a publicly traded company those
are real and the more you become
accountable to the actions if you're in
the military still and what the way
you're gonna be seen way the way your
unit is gonna be seen and perceived by
other senior leaders those are real
things and if you don't grow up you
don't make the progress that you need to
make yeah and I was lucky enough to see
that you know had some great examples
along the way great leaders that I work
for but it can be hard to see that yeah
and now that's a good like expression
when you said I I win it I opened my
eyes or I went in with open eyes I don't
even know how to describe it but I just
was aware of what was happening a little
bit more than normal or a little bit
more enough to make the changes I guess
yeah and that's the hard part
yeah and I think it is because of like
say like your ego and it's hard for me
to even really say that because like
even when I say the word eagle it really
like it registers as like this external
oh the guy walking around with his chest
out and I don't know his Mohawk I don't
know whatever it's like that it's an
external expression but it's not it's
like it's like being able to kind of
shed the blinders on self-critique and
say you know when someone tells you hey
like you're you're kind of acting this
way you're kind of this way and to be
able to be to figure to yourself that
this person could be right first and
then be mad at the fact that they
dissing salted you second of course
that's gonna be part of it I understand
but most times for I think most of you
pointing me included sometimes where the
fact that you step to me like that
impacts me more than what you're
actually saying I mean but if you don't
have the the ego in the way that you
describe it you'll you'll hear what
they're saying first and then decide
whether not to be mad at it you know
it's weird to is like as I talk about
this stuff like like when I talk about
detachment now I used to I used to not
know that word when I would tell guys to
do it this is even you know not that
long ago you know but I was telling the
teams but it took me a while in the
teams while I was trying to tell guys
that mm-hmm
but I didn't figure out the words yet
you know yeah that's just one example
right there's a bunch of examples like
that where I was trying to convey him I
would convey the message but I didn't
just have like a concise way to do it or
a clear way to do it but I was still
conveying the same message right and
maybe and that's another thing that
happens is as you get older and you get
more experienced you understand the
message yourself better just like when
you teach you - or you teach anything
the more you teach it the better you
understand it yeah and so as I taught
things I understood it better yeah and
so that's one thing that I think helps
out a lot and this is why it's an
example and the answer for me on so many
different things with leadership people
say what do I do with this young person
that doesn't listen what do I do this
person that isn't reaching their
potential was like
in charge of stuff because that's what
that's what I think helped me a lot was
even in my first platoon when I was a
youngest guy and I was the most junior
guy in my 1st platoon I was the I was
the head radio man mm-hmm which meant I
was responsible for stuff I which man I
sat through the briefs and I had to help
with the planning I had to do like stuff
that was outside my realm of experience
and I had to step up and do it
and it seems like a little thing right
now well I'll tell you what when you're
19 years old and you're in charge of the
communications for some training
exercise you know and you don't know
what the hell you're doing yeah step up
and figure that stuff out
yeah and that's that's very very
impactful so that's what you do with
your junior leaders that you want to
have them step up and lead you put them
in charge of things you put them that
was very lucky that I had leaders that I
work for that did that and I've talked
about it before I mean that leaders that
that put myself and the other junior
guys and platoons in charge of things
yeah not just not just saying what but
actually putting us in charge of things
and that that's a quick way to grow
leader so I was very lucky that I had
that and I think that was one of the
things that helped me to see the light
right was being put in charge of things
even at a young younger age when do you
think like how you just talked about
detaching right now where you were
trying to convey that message before you
even called it detaching yeah when did
you understand the importance of I've
told the story before here's I was I was
doing oil rigs training and we came up
on a platform out of an oil rig there
different platforms or different levels
I should say and we came up on this one
platform I was I think this was this
wasn't mice which I think it was my
first or second Platoon I'm pretty sure
it was my second platoon and as we came
up on this this level it was it was a
little confusing and the whole platoon
gets online and no one does anything and
I i basically stood there for a second
and then I kind of stepped back off the
lineup but let I looked around and I
said okay I see what we should do and I
actually said hold left clear right or
whatever this little call was and
everyone did it
and the only reason I understood that
was cuz I stepped back like a foot and
looked around and that's all you that's
what and and I realized right then oh if
I'm not staring down my gun if I take a
step back if I look around if I detach I
didn't use that word cuz I didn't know
that word right but I said oh you just
step back and you high port your gun and
you look around you're gonna know way
more than anybody else that's staring
down they're gone and that right there
changed my world it really did it
changed my world and at the time I
didn't think that changed my world I
just said oh cool you know what when
okay yeah when people are frozen take a
step back look around and didn't make a
call okay that's cool that's what I
started doing I didn't think it was a
big deal at the time I didn't think it
was a big deal until I was an instructor
position and I would see everyone
staring down their gun and no one making
decision and all I'd have to do is tell
someone hey take a step back with me
right here one foot back off the firing
line and look around and then go okay we
can go to this berm right here and we'll
be out okay yeah that's right then I
started to realize how important it was
and I started to put you know words
around it and put put messaging around
it that it was important and there's an
every lesson that I talked about was all
kind of learned in that method yeah all
that was kind of learned by being put in
situations where I had to figure
something out or something occurred or I
and that's the same thing with my life
we got put in some situation I said okay
you know what
and what what I think might be kind of
key about that particular idea of
detaching is is when you can detach in
life right it gives you this incredible
ability to see yourself and I think that
if we go down to the core of of myself
improving as a leader and continuing to
try and improve as a leader it's because
if you can detach and see yourself
because that's the same exact thing like
I mentioned this earlier I said you know
I kind of saw myself and saw how other
guys were seeing me well that you've got
to detach from be in order to see how
other people are seeing you you've got
to be able to detach a little bit and
understand it and so that ability to
step back and see myself
other people's to see myself in
situations and see how other people were
interacting with me was very very
helpful now this does not mean that I
was able to just correct course
overnight and I don't want to make that
you know anyone think that yeah and I
did dumb stuff when I was a when I was a
assistant platoon commander and I did
dumb stuff when I was a platoon
commander and I did dumb stuff when I
was at asking the commander and I did
dumb stuff when I was a training
commander and I dude I'm gonna do
something dumb tomorrow watch me but I
think I will recognize it most the time
I look at it and say you know what that
was dumb and don't do that again or
here's how you can avoid it and I think
that's what will help people if people
can can adapt that little skill of
stepping back off the off the line and
taking a look around to let taking a
look at yourself look at how you're
being perceived what else is important
is is how to actually think about how
EKKO is perceiving me right because if
I'm in my own head I can't I can never
see how you're seeing me but sometimes
if you're acting look the first thing I
do when someone's acting weird to me or
I don't understand why someone's acting
a certain way is I put myself in their
shoes it's hard to do that and if you
don't do that you don't make real you
can't understand them so if my boss is
doing something crazy to me and all I do
is get pissed at them for doing
something crazy
that's we've just created created an
antagonistic relationship and now things
are going sideways and it's not good if
my boss is doing something crazy I mean
I said wait a second why is he doing
this let me think about what he's saying
oh he's seeing Jaco the caveman looking
guy that wants to go out and he seems
crazy and okay I need to I need to
correct that I need to correct that
thing I need to let him see that I'm
thinking about the big picture and that
I understand the shot okay let me make
those adjustments yeah as opposed to
he's stupid he's using didn't screw him
No detach check other people's
perspectives yeah and that's a big key
right there where you were like you said
you know the the moment you kind of
maybe realized
this is the importance of the
significance of detaching the oil rig
campaign in this campaign was a training
are not that big of a deal to me that's
a campaign the and then how you
understood at whatever point that that
applies to life is because I man that's
I take those two things understanding
that you don't know everything
mm-hm and being able to detach which is
borderline impossible by the way under
most challenges yeah anyway as far as
applying it to life like because like
even in the military it's like that's a
very specific environment military like
unlike most environments seemingly like
if you could you know like house aqua
like I don't know going to the post
office or going to the grocery store
dealing with my wife or something like
that but like when you go deep enough
detaching is gonna serve the exact same
significance good and also duration you
know your your wife comes home you know
pissed because I don't know whatever you
know how you said the first reaction
what you feel like doing which you not
you but which one may typically do is
react accordingly according to how I
feel about this what you're saying to me
you shouldn't be saying this stuff to me
I didn't do anything - why are you doing
this to me
you know they're only dishes or whatever
escalate escalate asking you're just
thinking hey this isn't fair this is
wrong what you're doing to me so I'm
gonna you know exhibit that or whatever
but that's because you're not detached
like you just did and when you're able
to do it again borderline impossible but
what do you find it borderline
impossible have you made progress in
that arena look hugely no here's why
it's not borderline awesome no it's not
that's an expression okay it's it's
Jamie impossible it's worth lying upon
us it's borderline impossible because
that's the last thing you feel like
doing yeah
so if you operate in your life which is
natural by the way with how you feel you
know like I'm just wrestling myself you
know what it's like it's like this it's
like you're doing something
and you have to do something completely
different yeah right just imagine that
you're walking down the road and now all
of a sudden you're walking down the road
maybe you're even jogging you're jogging
down the road now all of a sudden in a
split second you've got to like go read
a book like right at that moment in time
while you're running it's like that
radical of a change like it's something
totally that's what it feels like when
you detach from the current situation
you're in this you're in this thing
you're in this thing and you have to
completely go and do something
completely different that's what it feel
it feels like that radical of the thing
when you when you really do it yeah and
when you do it right like when you're
enough you know let's say an argument
with someone a heated argument yeah it
feels like you're going from running of
thousand miles an hour to to like
putting your face in the snow and
reciting the alphabet backwards that's
it it's just totally different yeah and
so that you know that's why and people
are gonna ask and they've asked us
before well how do you detach and
although the biggest thing I think you
have to do is you have to figure out
what your red flags are what are the
things that show you that you're too
engulfed in the situation and then
recognize those things and then go put
your face in the snow and started
reciting the alphabet backwards if
that's what it feels like to detach yeah
but if you think about the advantage
that you have and and I know you're a
football player I'm not but you know you
can watch everybody that's watching the
football game on TV can see every
mistake that's being made as it's
happening and everyone else on the field
is there trying to they can't compensate
for him faster yes they're in the game
yeah and usually it's on the quarterback
by the way I think I was why I don't
been waiting yeah exactly exactly
hundred percent so you have that
advantage if you can do that yeah
if you can manage to do that in like
another cool thing about the situation
is yeah I say borderline impossible but
the more you can actually pull through
and do it the more you can do that the
easier it becomes and when it becomes
like habit and really all it is and you
can do weird like meadow which I'm kind
of a fan of doing little metaphors with
yourself you know so if it's like you
ever watch those movies know where
the movies going on and then the person
would call him the protagonist like it's
almost he pauses the movie and everyone
in the movie starts turning yeah you so
it's like you do that to yourself double
eat yourself is odd and so you go boom
wife comes home pissed you didn't I
don't know clean up the dogs whatever or
I don't know whatever you didn't mow the
lawn how about that she's pissed you can
easily move on tonight you can easily
mullet on tomorrow whatever right but
she's pissed right you don't think so so
what you do is right when you feel
yourself for right when you get her
yelling at you don't pause the movie
what do we have here what do we have
here we have myself
we have wife she's mad at something does
it make sense what would make you know
it's like then you just detach it that
way I don't think it makes sense yeah
how are you solved you can like this are
you like you know he said like the
football game when you if you can pause
the movie at that at that point step
back you will easily because you'll be
like oh guess what my wife I haven't
been home for four days yeah I left a
bunch of laundry out yeah the baby was
diaper was dirty and I forgot to throw
it away
um okay I see where she's she's not mad
about the wall specifically there's
worse things that are drunk and so you
say hey you know what I totally should
have moved one and by the way the
diapers that was that was completely out
and you know I mean and and you defuse
and you de-escalate the situation you're
detached and that's how you that's how
you roll yeah that's how you make it
through it here's a little side tip on
that situation along the diapers or
whatever it's not that that the grass is
long and she wants it short and the fact
that it's long is making her mad that's
not the situation the situation is she
said something she thought that that
meant something that she said something
she thought it meant something to you
when it came time to prove whether or
not that meant something to you you
proved it in it that's what you're
dealing that's what you guys are dealing
with and that's easy to figure out when
you detach it's what I figured out when
you're in the heat of the moment yeah
when you're in the game it's hard to see
who's open and who's not some of the
time most of the time for sure all the
time
thank you all right next
next question I think this question is a
good good lead that last answer was a
good lead-in to this next question yeah
how do you think young Jocko would have
performed under commander Willie oh yeah
you see that reaction that you just had
yeah is what I expected because it seems
like it should be like a really
interesting question like a really
interesting answer but it actually isn't
that interesting to me to be quite
honest with you if young Jocko was
working for old Jocko it would've been
good to go I would have liked me as a
young guy and as a young guy I would
like me as a boss I was a young hard
worker with a good attitude and
sometimes I got a little bit wild as I
mentioned a little bit earlier but I
could have been tightened up by the
right leader and I wasn't like I wasn't
I wasn't it wasn't ever interfering with
work and all your wild wild my wildness
you know we're getting wild we were
young young guys with a fistful of money
and young guys so we're just getting
after it and you know the guys but but
we weren't like causing major trouble
right we weren't getting arrested much
yeah we weren't getting in fights all
the time you know we were causing some
problems but it wasn't nothing major so
we do bunt tighten up and we got
tightened up sometimes but it would be
no factor and as a young guy um you know
I think I would uh I would have liked
working for me because I would have
looked at myself and did not know that
guys fired up he wants to get after it
and that would have been cool with me so
so again I don't think it's I don't
think it's like it sounds like a really
interesting question but it's not really
that interesting and the cool thing is
there's a lot of young team guys that
are like I was when I was a young team
guy yeah it's right so I was like I was
looked at all young team guys like I am
a member I was like that good for him
yeah
hey good friend he's fired up would
there be any issues though you know like
well as young Jocko who do you think or
die who but what do you think would be
your major struggle
you know it any even with my with Jocko
the boss yeah yeah
nah no we would have been cool huh
we'd been cool yeah yeah then into the
fact that matter is I mean like 95% of
the Young Buck team guys that worked for
me yeah I love those guys yeah you know
they were awesome
and no issues yeah so you're you were
like you're essentially on the path then
really you know with some loose ends for
sure oh yeah yeah was on the path yeah
and you know my my the guys that I got
went to buds with that showed up at SEAL
team one broke their duty I won't sit
old Jocko would love duffel is yeah
they're all fired up I was nothing spent
I don't know I'm not trying to say I was
special because I wasn't there's guys
that were way better than me and you
know that's to go back to your question
earlier when I described myself like as
my good quality being durable the reason
I say that is because like there's guys
that were better at me than that just
about everything like faster than me
stronger than me better shots than me
whatever I was pretty durable though
like I was pretty I was good at being
average at a lot of different things I
was a strong average and a lot of
different things which is good and I was
durable like I could I could take some
abuse mental and physical abuse which is
a cool quality to have you know yeah
very much so
like a tank that just can't you know
yeah and again I'm not trying to sit I'm
no Superman but I'm durable you know
that makes sense you know the you know
like the the Toyota Hilux do you know
the Toyota Hilux this is it's a it's a
Toyota truck they have them overseas
their diesel and they're really really
durable really there's a there's a show
from England my wife's from England
there's a show in England
it's called Top Gear my son watches the
show Top Gear they tried to destroy at a
Toyota Hilux did they were doing like
just crazy things to me it's a really
durable it's not the fastest it's not
the strongest yeah you know you know but
it's durable durable is a good quality
to have just I got asked the other day
you should do Olympic lifting I'm like
bro
not even in the mall parked you know
compete with me just crazy talk crazy
yeah I'm sorry anything then you start
competing you better yah yeah yeah yeah
crazy talk
so yeah Yong Yong Yong Bob Jaco he would
had a good time and old Jocko like I
said man there's there's a ton of young
team guys they got fired up I was I was
out with some young team I was out with
some team guys and there were some young
young team guys there and some of these
young team guys awesome
I'm like yeah you know what you know
people say like all Millennials and this
and then we do America's getting weak
I'm like go hang out with some of those
guys you know they're 20 years old I'm
like you know what we're good to go yeah
we're good to go
we got to know guys that are beast solid
yeah yeah beyond solid freakin awesome
yeah my my two friends that are in the
picture I mean cake nuts think talking
to them now like the maturity level is
just really like really impressive
maturity level especially for both them
but at the same time thinking back on
them and how they kind of when they
started when they're like yeah we're but
in the SEAL Teams all this stuff
considering that and then considering
where they are now it makes it seem like
the same to me we're older them wouldn't
have a problem really like they were on
the path or a path for sure those are
kinda guys I'm talking about like those
guys were I would love that those guys
working for me when I was a when I was a
commander and I would love to have those
guys as my chief when I was a young guy
ya know no factor yeah so like I said I
think people thought that sounded like
an interesting question but it actually
wasn't yeah finally shit yeah what about
socially though no not socially but what
do you say like you know like outside of
the military you know yeah I mean I was
a young kid
yeah but the older guy you look at the
young kids and you go yeah you know he's
young yeah he's getting after it blossom
let's rock and roll
I gotta let me keep him out of trouble
yeah that's all good all good I think I
might have some problems with myself
Decco focus yoga wasn't on the path yet
no I don't know yeah there was no path I
didn't see a path really all right next
question what advice would Jocko give
his 17 year old self regarding school
social relationships parents peer
pressure etc yes like the actual Jocko
podcast tonight is these questions are
about a job yeah okay that's kind of
what I was asking like outside of the
military yeah you know if I was gonna
tell myself something here's a couple
things that you know I would tell myself
too did you hatch I tell myself to learn
that I would tell myself that that girl
isn't the whole world yeah and it was
friends aren't the last friends you're
ever gonna have and the party isn't
gonna be the best party of all time and
all those things that you think is what
we talked about earlier all those things
that you think are a huge deal when
you're young they're not a big deal and
I know that's kind of messed up but it's
true man it's true the things that you
think are a big deal when you're 17
years old yeah not that big of a deal
and it's really hard to convince someone
that 17 years old of that right they
also also what they don't recognize is
things that are a big deal
they don't recognize they think they're
a little deal right so they're doing
stupid things right yeah whether it's
drinking and driving whether I mean kids
still drink and drive now like yeah how
dumb is that
yeah and so people don't think you know
nowadays we've talked about social media
reach it but people post stuff on social
media and you come and what is wrong
with you you know I've heard now you
know we work with a lot of different
companies when you apply for a job they
go and look at your social media and see
what kind of an idiot you might be hey
that's a good movement no it's a great
move it's a great move so yeah just just
recognize that some of the little things
are actually big and some of the big
things are actually little and I'd
square those things away and the I've
said this before when you're young
you've got to realize that how you act
now is directly related to your future
success to your future hat
as to your future financial situation to
everything so so it's hard to make that
connection right we are young impossible
it might be impossible some kids get it
though I'm telling you some kids get it
I think they're just no some kids get it
some of my oldest daughters friends they
get it like they're on track yeah
they're on track they're like hey I'm
doing this I'm doing that they're on
track they're 16 years old they're
studying for the SATs they're taking the
AP classes
my daughter included like they're on
track to make stuff happen yeah but I
think and I'm not saying this is the
case but this is probably the case one
way or another I could be wrong man but
okay so and we talked about this before
you in that part of your brain that
understands all that that you're talking
about that's near develop develop so
this is you know and this is from what I
understand how you kind of influence
people you just put them on a routine
kind of like okay so it's the difference
between understanding like what I'm
doing now and having it tangible no
untested I know where you're going with
us
and your UI I believe that there are
definitely some kids like that that are
just they're just like hey okay I'm
supposed to get good grades maybe a
great deal on that track I know for a
fact kids that are like no I am going to
do this this this and it's gonna lead me
here actually you know what you're right
cuz this is good Blake you know remember
Blake I used to do videos for ya so he
we did like a thing where it was I think
he's like a Q&A or something like that
and he was he was talking about that
where in elementary school he remembers
feeling like if if I don't have perfect
attendance and you have perfect straight
A's I won't pass this not pass but I
won't like be the the perfect guy or
whatever and he said that he would you
would like create like this track to his
whole future and his life would be
ruined
that's how he found it whoa-ho so I'm
living like minutes a minute and the
reason I wanted to do my homework and
get good grades is so I wouldn't get in
trouble straight straight not to get
into college it was sure none of that
stuff for sure and then that's the way
most kids are in line
opinion most kids are a I don't want to
get in trouble some immediate
repercussions myself included yeah hey I
gotta pass this so I can go to the next
grade
yeah and stuff yeah or I don't want to
be the guy in class who didn't do his
homework you know kind of thing yeah but
yeah I guess so yeah I guess so that's
that's me trying to I got a step outside
myself on that one and I guess the final
thing obviously I tell myself discipline
equals freedom which is basically what
we're saying yeah so get this wondering
how you live your life I think the
biggest one there is to to whether they
totally understand that or not say like
what you're doing right right now is the
important things in life the things that
you think are important or not are not
important and then things that aren't
that you think are not important are
important so it's kind of like a like an
iceberg you know I'll be old you know
the people that watch over that little
statement you know why cuz people really
like the way you say important you said
eight times the flurry of glory and and
rainbows emojis yes I agree with you
so like the iceberg thing you know you
know the iceberg metaphor where it's
like people only see the top of the
iceberg below that is like this huge
iceberg so that's what that's what
important things are in life right so
you think it's just this little small
little iceberg but when you think of the
whole scope of life would you have no
access to by the way as yet it's that
whole iceberg you know so if you're not
focusing on that important part of the
iceberg well I guess an iceberg
situation is not that important but yeah
another metaphor but it'll sink your
ship yeah yeah you know they like in
that kind of situation um but and then
at the same time the things that aren't
really important meaning they don't have
an iceberg under there they're just
little floaty thing yeah you think
that's so important that thing's gonna
melt or get crowded or whatever you know
not gonna thank you no it's not gonna
think it's just you know kind of its
fleeting check a one thing before we
closed out tonight because I think
that's good for questions I want to hit
a couple quick Tim Ferriss this new book
I want to hit a couple quick things from
it
tribal mentors is what it's called and
a lotta good info on it and it's written
in really short little sections if you
didn't know this yet I mean you can read
them in like 5 or 10 minutes and what he
did in this book is he took and asked
the same I think it's 10 or 11 questions
to all these different I would say
random but they're not random because
they're all kind of successful in
whatever realm they're gonna be
successful in because guess successful
is a very open term right whatever realm
they're in they're successful as all
kinds of people in here and I just I
read like the first couple 150 pages or
so and I just wanted to pull out a
couple of the couple of ones that I
thought were pretty cool that I thought
people could take a little something
away from and I was like Tim canary a
couple of these things he's like yeah go
ahead
whatever hopefully doesn't sue me
anyways so here we go the first one is a
little section from some excerpts and
I'm not reading the whole like
everything in each person's section but
just some of the highlights Steven
Pressfield the guy's an author he's in
the Marine Corps you know who's Steven
Pressfield us yeah he wrote the art of
war he wrote The Legend of Bagger Vance
that's a war of art yeah sorry he wrote
the war of art yeah which is obviously a
play on words for the art of war and the
war of art is like how to be creative
and how to overcome those things to
overcome the resistance and all that yes
and Joe Rogan actually told me he used
to have a stack those books and he just
give them to people I came to meet him
yeah that's why I read it
oh there you go and he also wrote gates
a fire which is a freakin awesome book
actually and it's about the Spartans the
Battle of Thermopylae and they actually
teach gates of fire like at the basic
school for the Marine Corps and at the
Naval Academy at least I've heard that
they've teach it so that's pretty that's
pretty awesome anyways here's
question four Steven Pressfield the
question is what advice would you give
to a smart driven college student about
to enter the real world what advice
should they ignore here's what he said
I'm probably hopelessly out of date but
my advice is get real-world experience
be a cowboy drive a truck join the
Marine Corps get out of the hyper
competitive life hack frame of mind I'm
74 believe me you've got all the time in
the world you've got ten lifetimes ahead
of you don't worry about your friends
beating you or getting somewhere ahead
of you get out and get into the real
dirt world and start failing why do I
say that because the goal is to connect
with your own self your own soul
adversity everybody spends their life
trying to avoid it me too but the best
things that ever happened to me came
during the times when the shit hit the
fan and I had nothing and nobody to help
me who are you really what do you really
want get out there and fail and find out
pretty much what's funny I was talking
to Jade last night literally last night
he told me the same thing get out there
and fail what what part that what that
thing it's like you know live so me when
I step outside of my comfort zone I take
one tiny step and here's the thing told
you to jump he told me to like take a
bigger jump kind of thing he didn't tell
me to do it he just recommended it cuz
well you know my whole and this is
probably half justification by the way I
have a comfort zone I'll take one tiny
step and then all I'll take the you know
when you step aside you get burned or
whatever you get you know that whatever
and then you grow from it that's what
happens that's the whole idea right so I
take a tiny step then I take the tiny
hit and then I get the tiny growth but I
try to do it all the time all the time
well Sam but it's still safe man that's
still safe because that's just like one
pinkie outside the comfort zone that's
what he was saying he was like you like
you get a step outside cuz just the fact
that you can endure a big fail you know
you see and go out there and feel
alright it's best feel so if you can
endure
like a big fail or two big fails or
major fails now you have the ability to
endure major failure you know that kind
of thing that's that's his whole thing
like yeah that makes sense
I didn't tell him that at the time it's
like now that I'm doing it perfect track
next question for Steven Pressfield when
you feel overwhelmed or unfocused what
do you do and here's his answer I have a
friend at the gym who knew Jack LaLanne
Google him if the name is unfamiliar
Jack used to say it's okay to take a day
off from working out but on that day
you're not allowed to eat that's the
short way of saying you're not really
allowed to get unfocused take a vacation
gather yourself but know that the only
reason you're here on this planet is to
follow your star and do what the muse
tells you it's amazing how a good day's
work will get you right back to feeling
like yourself that's good info right
there when I realize this it's so easy
to go down the downward spiral of the
bad food feel bad not get good workouts
sleep late sleep like crap and and then
what do you do when you feel like crap
you want to feel better as soon as
possible so you do some immediate
gratification right you you go and you
know what I don't feel like working out
so I'm not gonna work out
yeah and then you say you know what I
don't feel good and the reason you don't
feel good is could you didn't work out
and so now which news you like well do
you know what's gonna make me feel
better a doughnut and a beer and a beer
mmm and so you get the doughnut in the
beer and then now you really don't feel
like working out so that's the downward
spiral you know break the spiral break
it break would you call them if the
other day when Jordan Peterson was on
break the loop yeah yeah so that's the
same thing you gotta break the loop and
that's what he's talking about when
you're feeling like crap get after it
that's that's what
how I translated and it makes you feel
better and it gets you right back on the
path yeah and that's why actually
fasting is a good thing yeah fasting is
a good way to get yourself free
reacquainted with the path real quick
you fill your body with a bunch of junk
yeah it makes you not want to perform it
makes you not want to workout it makes
you not want to work yeah when you're
clean you feel good so hit it fast 24
hours you know yeah rock and roll yeah
and I like that you want to take a day
off that's cool no evening how legit is
that it's real shit it's a real legit
cuz now guess what at lunchtime you like
man I just want to eat something cool go
bang and then I can get your grub on
or you can work out and still not eat
all right getting into the next cat here
this guy's name is Jersey Gregor ik and
this guy immigrated from Poland the
United States as a political refugee
with his wife in 1986 and he won
subsequently won four world
weightlifting championships and
established one world record record
founded the UCLA weightlifting team and
by the way this guy's been on this guy's
been on Tim's podcast as well this guy
Jersey also writer write poem broke
poems and had award-winning poems but
this is kind of a cool little statement
that he wrote in here he kind of goes on
a little bit of a tangent the kiss isn't
related to the question but I want to
jump into it he says five years ago I
decided to eliminate my reactive
behavior to irritations but at first
none of my tricks worked
I placed philosophical and inspirational
quotes on my iPhone wall paper and wrote
in my journal
but the Proverbs always lost their
effectiveness over time then one day I
told one of my clients who blamed her
husband for everything to take 100%
responsibility for her part in the
interactions
this way I said you will be free of
trying to control him and you will be
able to find constructive solutions in
your relationship when she left I
realized that the same advice could help
me as well taking 100% personal
responsibility would help me to stop
blaming or complaining and achieve a
sense of flow it would also give me the
clarity in any conversation to locate
the right words to help a person accept
a hard choice so he's talking about
extreme ownership and and we talked
about that we're in taking her taking
extreme ownership in a relationship with
another human being don't blame them
figure out how you're gonna solve the
problem yourself you know what this
reminded me of was when captain plum was
on and he was had a cellmate and what
they do you remember captain plum and he
touched on it but he was saying that if
their cellmate was annoying them because
believe you know they're the living with
one other or two other or three other
people for months on end in a little
freaking Hanoi Hilton cell and he said
if that person because you can imagine
how you get on each other's nerves and
they all took the attitude if they
allowed themselves if EKKO is getting on
my nerves it wasn't necklace fault it
was my fault yeah yeah my fault yeah and
that's what he's talking about here then
you can actually fix it that the next
question that jersey answered is this
one if you could have a gigantic
billboard anywhere with anything on it
what would it say and why and here we go
here's what his answer was
hard choices easy life easy choices hard
life nothing truly meaningful or lasting
has ever been created in a short period
of time if you learn the story behind
any great success you realize how many
years went by and how many hard choices
were made to achieve it reaching for
more is not only an act of ambition it
also becomes it also comes from passion
and love nothing is achieved because of
easy choices I believe that people can
endure any hardship if it is sensible
and constructive hard choices means
never retiring because the brain has to
be engaged in finding new solutions in
the moment
not just remembering old formulas hard
choices make us wiser smarter stronger
and wealthier and easy choices reverse
our progress focusing our energies on
comfort or entertainment in every
difficult moment ask yourself what is a
hard choice and what is an easy choice
and you will know instantly what is
right does that even need commentary not
really that's a great thing to think
about yeah discipline equals freedom
discipline is hard man yeah you know he
said like pay now or pay later kind of
you know good you want to pay later or
if you want a lot of people they try to
pay later
you know yeah I heard one the other day
you can either suffer the pain of
discipline or the pain of regret right
same thing same thing exactly people
saying the same thing must mean
something
yeah it must mean something pay
attention to it yeah all right
moving to the next section here page 127
from tribal mentors Amelia Boone and she
wakes up at like 3 o'clock in the
morning she's legit and she's four-time
world champion in the sport of obstacle
course racing I met her a couple times
you met her too yeah yeah she's a beast
and what's cool about her is she beats
like she did the 2012 world's toughest
Mudder competition it's 24 hours 90
miles 300 obstacles she finished second
overall out of more than a thousand
competitors including 80 percent of
which are male second overall did I say
something about being durable earlier
that's durable so Amelia awesome human
and a lot last one will do here but she
she got our steel the same question if
you could have a gigantic billboard
anywhere with anything on it what would
you say and why and Amelia says no one
owes you anything we live in a world
that's rampant with entitlement with
many people believing that they deserve
to be given more my parents raised me to
be self-sufficient and it pressed upon
me that the only person you can really
depend on them in life is you if you
want something you work for it you don't
expect it to be given if others help you
along the way that's fantastic but it's
not a given I believe that the key to
self-sufficiency is breaking free of the
mindset that someone somewhere owes you
something or will come to your rescue
no one owes you anything no one's coming
to your rescue it's on you obviously I
couldn't agree more that's funny because
as she said I mean we we know the
importance of a team and you always hear
people say you know you can't do it by
yourself and I'm not here I'm here
because of so many different people and
that's true but that doesn't mean that
you can sit around and rely on other
people to save you or to do the heavy
lifting or even help you out in any
other way help from other people is a
luxury it's a luxury that you shouldn't
count on so step up and own it and make
it happen because no one owes you
anything that book is tribal mentors
Timothy Ferriss he's got Timothy not Tim
anymore Timothy Ferriss short life
advice from the best in the world all
right speaking of helping people echo
Charles yeah maybe you can help people
learn how to support themselves yeah and
maybe if they want to also
simultaneously support this podcast if
they want to that that would be
fantastic but we're not relying on it
I'm hoping it's not hey I got this I'll
run with it
sure oh yeah sure of course sure you
want me to run with it cuz I'll be done
with it like four minutes right here
what's interesting is that kind of
depend on you and rely on you to kind of
help bail me out this podcast otherwise
they'd just be kind of talking to myself
yeah okay Jack actually I wouldn't be
talking because I typically talk after
you talk like in reaction to you so if
it was the echo podcast it would just be
silence yeah wouldn't even be good
evening because you say good
no podcast Jack so good
so yeah support yourself right all right
we'll talk about crude oil chuckles
Croyle
chuckles super krill oil super super
grill yeah and also Jocko joint warfare
glucosamine chondroitin this is offer
your joints the best type of supplement
in my opinion you know when have you
been into other supplement yeah so I've
I have like you my younger days where I
take like I don't know protein powder
like this thing does this you know I can
say with full on honesty that when I'd
stop taking it there what happens when
you stop taking down that's the thing
yeah so there is a difference and
especially I mean oh no I'm I'm whatever
age I am now you don't have to go into
that part but so I don't know I don't
know how it is to take krill oil when I
was like in my 20s so I don't know yeah
you know I think but I know now and I'll
tell you this and I have gotten off it
for like a it was like maybe a week a
little a little bit more than a week and
yeah they could they came back man the
joint situation yes you know what I
think you know and I think the krill oil
and the joint warfare do mm-hmm
make it durable yeah you dirty do I
believe they contribute greatly to my
durability
yeah and that's and it's actually saying
a lot for me cuz and for YouTube
big-time because you're you're not like
a small guy you know a smaller person
and let's face it we're older than we
were before it's a true statement
you you we you actually more so than me
you do like hard stuff
yeah like lifting jiu-jitsu like hard
stuff yeah sure harder than the normal
person maybe some people not Amelia boom
yeah ninety 390 miles awesome yeah see
what after she's not already on it yeah
or something like it nonetheless the
joint situation
is like that's saying a lot if you can
do the stuff that you do and I just kind
of doing some introspection kind of
detaching whatever I'm looking at stuff
that I do it's like man it helps a lot I
don't think I'd be able to go as hard Oh
No when you definitely want to like just
daily my shoulder healed yeah my elbow
straight of them yeah boom there you go
and my knees put abuse on my knees with
with like working out and you just
because they're kind of loose skin skin
but um like they're super loose where
when I blew out my knee in college the
doctor when he you know they do the
tests I'm like okay before they do that
MA right they do the tests and all these
tests they just kind of wiggle them and
do all this stuff from different
positions and they wiggled both of them
and they're like bro your knees are
loose is just genetic doctors telling
you that they were skinny too they were
loose and then you said you at skinny I
do and skinny ankles get up right now I
then I hurt my knee when I was rolling
with Greg and I went to the doctor who
performed the surgeon bicep and he did
he was like oh yeah you have a blown AC
up and I was like whoa I only have I
hurt the outside of Mini or the inside
of my knee not the outside or not my I
didn't blow out my nose like no you blew
out your knee I was like dang I was like
oh but but he didn't run any
comprehensive tests he just did it real
quick like wiggled it and then I was
like whoa my doctor in college said I
have really loose knee so check this one
and there is he had like another person
there and he goes thumb and he checks
the other he's like whoa whoa
but the difference is when you wiggle a
note ACL knee it doesn't like abruptly
stop even if it's loose so I'm saying so
like if you have no ACL it's like boo
it's like a blunt like yeah it's like if
you had a big a cord in there like a
real tear like a tension cord or
something that didn't didn't stretch at
all and mine are just a little bit
longer
nonetheless so the point is I know long
expressed and when I rolled you just so
they'll pop out
sometimes loosens and then if if they
pop out and then I'd like kick or
straighten out real quick or whatever
it'll pop out in you know you you bones
they're kind of shaped like this they'll
do this and then they'll get like caught
on each other and when they get caught
on each other and you press it'll like
mess up the car leaves yeah so they'll
get swollen on the inside at the end of
the day they get swollen for like some
days like warm amount more or whatever
but yeah i taked I just stick to krill
oil no no I just ignore the swelling
you know factor and I'm pretty flexible
to check nonetheless anyway you want to
support yourself there you go Jocko
supercro oil and joint warfare boom
physical support on your supportive
structures also if you're indeed you
Jitsu origin has a new key what is it
your signature key is that we call don't
know about all that
yeah says cool stuff on it yeah pickles
freedom get after it
yeah so I guess technically as far as
what a signature something here yeah
that's the jockey it's not called the
jockey no we wouldn't be having I guess
we have a taco but that's just for a
lack of a better name really true this
one yeah anyway they eat the death key
yep discipline equals freedom key is it
good on kind of lighter weight it's um
Pete oldc Pete said the did the weave
you're like it's an athletic weave it's
a real weave yeah it's not just taking
cotton which is what which is what they
just make pants from 1908 from yeah it's
an athletic and when you put it in the
dryer or you put in the washing machine
when you get done it's almost right it's
got cotton in it but it's also got a
poly blend yeah yeah and it's all made
here in America from the seed of the
cotton the very seed that you plant the
seed I wonder if where they get the
seeds from Charlie here and I think it's
either Tennessee or South Carolina yeah
so we'll find out yeah you've been
buying the seeds or acquiring the seeds
in whatever capacity yeah
who's here in America planted in America
cotton grows in America harvested in
America obviously died in
America died in America up to Maine
repeat weaves it and a bunch of loans
into fabric and into geez boom right on
your back distant rolling all made in
America that's all the stuff and
merchants by the way if you don't know
already they got some good rash guards
and compression gear which is what the
same thing yes sergeant comprised
noticed because I didn't used to use
rash guards other than for surfing yeah
do you notice you feel a little bit like
the compression helps you athletically
do you feel that I don't feel that no
but the I don't think I'm paying
attention to be honest with you classy
bum just straps what about people that
get nineteen percent improvement in
their jujitsu skills that's real that's
aerial but you know this farce good but
I hear good things about compression mmm
like I see the links to articles that
say all the performance benefits and all
this stuff here's the thing I don't read
them I don't know
so I wear kneepads when I roll yeah and
I wear them for two reasons well I wear
them for three reasons number one just
abrasions on the knee right whatever
Matt burn on your knee which is cool you
get it maybe you get it maybe get it
once every three days that's once every
three days you got Matt burn on your
knee and you get blood and you got
people that are like hey I don't want to
roll with you because you're bleeding or
whatever so that's just a pain number
two it for me
keeps him warm right all right sleeves
just get just warms up your knees and
number three it provides a little bit of
compression that makes me feel good now
I feel when I put on a rash guard I feel
like that on my body which is good yeah
I don't know I think it feels good yeah
compression Giro I I can't speak really
on it but I for damn sure can't speak
against it and it's all made in American
America and they're dope do some
research yeah yeah if that even matters
you know does that matter that much well
well you wear it because it's
efficient to roll in for sure yeah the
most efficient thing you can roll in is
a rash guard yeah I feel like like hey
that's the uniform be all the booty call
it
ergonomic never economic it's like you
know how like he said the Matt Bernie
you don't get mapperton like all day
every day is just like yeah if you if
you're going super hard and your knee or
your elbow or whatever it happens to be
against the mat at it you know it's like
it's a happenstance situation unless
you're new
unless you're new you're in that burn
all over weird the way your body loves
proprioception to keep you from getting
a notice if you haven't rolled for a
long time you'll get your feet all Matt
Berger if your knees get all matter
turned up no you know when you're when
you know when you're in the role mode
you barely get Matt Burd yeah get it
like once every three or four rolls
well once every three or four days
you'll get a little Matt burn on top of
your toes yeah bro I haven't had Matt
burnt on my toes in like long time oh
it's like yes like your skin gets smart
like oh what are we doing rolling okay
we gotta toughen up right now have you
ever rolled on a like a rez light
wrestling mat barefoot after you've been
rolling on a hard to Tommy mat for a
while it takes like a week to get used
to it why cuz you will stub your toe a
bunch cuz your toes won't know where to
go because they're different softer yeah
it's like when you play football on
grass and good artificial turf you gotta
get you stay yeah it's weird
yeah anyway cool compression gear good
I'm glad that it's compression because
some people do care about that and I
think that you know one of those people
so if you know the benefits in your
benefiting from it there you go
boom I just I don't think I just been
paying attention but after this guess
what I will because I'm not always right
about things as far as the way I look at
them also also I want to talk about on
it so I would go into my whole
kettlebell routine which they smashed
yesterday by the way I got a new Cyclops
one by the way so again cool if you got
regular kettlebells the regular ones
that's good cuz doing kettlebells is way
better than not doing it
when I recommend so you get the good
ones the dope decorative artistic duck I
don't like decorative you like
decorative the more decadent no huh here
to win artistic artistic kettlebells I
say get those ones but they're just way
cool especially if you're into Instagram
stuff that's what i think my opinion
nonetheless they got regular ones as
well go to on it calms last chocolate
they have a bunch of fitness stuff I
noticed
Jacko's mace that II recommend I use for
like other stuff which is actually part
of a big point that you can use a lot of
this stuff for like various different
sorts of exercise activities yeah and
they have like a bunch of cool stuff on
there like um stuff that's different
from your traditional bench squat
you know like functional stuff check
unless buckle go there boom support
yourself expand your work up man if you
want you could be like Jaco do the same
thing over and over and over
actually there and over and over very
yeah but they vary over and over they
also have some strong actually I do the
same exact work out all the time with
variations but those variations will
come in the cycles that go over yeah but
that's kind of the whole point of a
workout though yeah it's like your body
gets used to certain activities you
can't let it get too used to it that's
why they say any gonna switch it up all
the shock your body all this stuff but
if you're constantly just shocking your
body it's like okay we're doing your
body's kind of saying this to you say
okay what are we doing I'm gonna get as
good at it as possible okay so however
many times we got to do this thing I'm
gonna try to my best as long as you feed
me and rest me I'm gonna try my best to
accommodate you as far as you know
getting better at this thing know if you
give me one thing to do and say get good
at that we're never doing it again you
know there's no real results except for
maybe the underlying system you know
maybe like your heart rate or your you
know those types of things maybe your
what do you call your you know when you
can endure like hard stuff meant durable
yeah like mental durability maybe that
but know if you do like one exercise
sure you
be sore and then that's kind of in the
benefits of that program won't really
then again I don't know I could be wrong
I could be missing like some new science
on the deal nonetheless research it get
a good workout routine and if you want
to expand it gonna on it because they
have the good stuff also if you want to
get Timothy Faris's book that chocolate
was quoting chocolate in there by the
way how many time any code to you oven
so these and they're the same right
they're the same as the same all the
before all this stuff yeah and here's
the thing like Tim will post like little
excerpts of like just little quotes you
know and that's a really interesting
thing that he did there where he asked
everyone the same question oh yeah
because that's the type of person Tim's
personality he looks for patterns yeah
that's how you find patterns that's
super sampling like it's so it's
basically you have eleven categories of
advice that you can get from these top
level people in different like industry
is different and then he's got like he's
kind of sorts them in the back so you
can see what everyone he kind of
assembles the information in some
various ways in the back of the book so
you can sort of pull yeah pool the
knowledge yeah man that's a creeper
that's good yeah man I actually like
that kind but that is smart though so
that's essentially what you have you
have this big book of advice from all
these completely experts that is exactly
what it is yeah
so there you go when you get that and
just go to here look we'll offer it
Jaakko podcast.com go on the top top
menu books from the episodes boom I got
you right there tribe of mentors by
Timothy Ferriss click through there it's
a good way to support if you want to
shop for anything else good do that
carry on man support away some people
think that that's not a big deal it is a
big deal just clicking through there I
mean it is a big deal well it's hard to
do easy to do it's small action small
action big reaction
you know it's like sodium when you throw
it into water anyway subscribe to the
podcast YouTube that's for the video
version but on iTunes and Google Play
stitcher a lot podcasting providing
platforms seems seems obvious but you
know if you haven't already subscribed
it's good way to support also YouTube
like I said video version of this
podcast also excerpts if you want to
share little ideas that have emerged
from the podcast you want to share them
individually they're on there most of
them I'll work on them every week put
them on there you can sure it's good
reason to subscribe to the YouTube also
I'll put some you know how people what's
called dislike mashups they're called
mashups yeah when you put like an
excerpt of your voice on there for music
videos yes they put some video so you
know some visual aid is what it's called
where do you make mashup make I don't
here's the thing though so a mash-up is
like you just take various clips you
know of whatever you know like they're
just visually you do like a whole
somatic thing and that's kind of the
thing so I don't know in a while though
isn't it really you think about it I
don't know
sometimes it's alright yeah Connor no
block read the war of art or I might be
just working diligently and obsessively
on maybe new approaches and methods put
the war of art on the pot on our site
too so people can get that the war of
art yeah I read that one there's good
yeah I I need to maybe revisit it for
this my video production standpoint
nonetheless when I do make those videos
I put them on YouTube and that's yet
another reason to subscribe on top of
the fact that it does support the
podcast so it's like a big circle loop
of support you see them saying also
jocular the store it's called chocolate
or chocolate or calm is where you can
get your discipline equals to freedom
shirt get after it's shirt and other
shirts of that type also rash guards on
their new rash guards on their
two new rush cards on there I don't know
two or three you got to look chuckle
putt or jaw closed or calm the rash
guard is sodium small action reaction
that's a rash guard I don't know the day
yeah yeah I got to take the pictures I
got a list them you know so during that
process hopefully sound like that's real
hard anyone want a job out there in the
world anyway a hard time taking pictures
of a rash guard warrior kid rash guards
for youth nice for the warrior kids
themselves so look out for that my
little daughter was sporting hers today
I know it looks good it looks very very
very very good nonetheless they're on
their roster icon got some hats on their
beanies coming as well um and you know
other stuff
yes I'm not saying goodbye a beanie I'm
not saying that you might not need one
maybe you're not ye yeah but you're
being you know why just for though dick
yeah but maybe you're in shy town yeah
and you need to be here in Michigan
somewhere
dang nonetheless gone there if you like
something get something good way to
support also psychological warfare on
your campaign against weakness that's
what we're going with right now campaign
against weakness improving yourself
you're going from a person who with who
is incapable of detaching who's
incapable of understanding the message
rather than your feeling about the
message your if you're that person yet
you're on the path to become a different
person someone who can understand the
message first feeling second the ability
to detach we're always working on and if
you're working on that as well this is
what you do you hit those moments of
weakness you have this album with tracks
chocolate tracks called psychological
warfare what it does is it takes any
little element of your campaign against
weakness you need little element that
you might slip on that you might see
that yeah sounded like you're at there
yeah might slip on it Oh
maybe a little weak when you wake up or
when you're about to wake up when you're
about to get up when you wake up you're
about to get up it's 4:30 and you're
like dang I'm gonna press the snooze
don't worry there's a track for that you
play that track chuckle give you
pragmatic advice on why you shouldn't
hit the snooze same thing goes for
skipping your workout same thing goes
for skimping on your diet slipping on
your diet creative bla progressive all
these things it's like tracks for wear
chocolates telling you why you shouldn't
do that like hey don't do that you know
this is why this is why why it's
beneficial for you to continue all that
stuff it's a good one it helps 100%
effective in spotting people when they
need a little spot if then if if you
need a spot sometimes you don't need a
spot sometimes you're just getting after
hundred percent that's a bit unfortunate
you like to win
if you don't believe me go read the
reviews on there I'll read some of them
us again I read a couple of them on here
but you can read them yourself the
reviews explain that when you drink
jockle white tea you can deadlift
8,000 pounds at a minimum so that's a
guarantee yeah people don't understand
guaranteed yeah yeah if you don't think
if you can't I'll give you your money
back to the table also got some books
you can get them anywhere really weigh
the warrior kid thank you everyone that
gives me feedback all the time kids that
are doing various things like studying
like reading the book studying doing
jiu-jitsu doing pull-ups swimming
competing just all kinds of awesome
stuff everything from figure skating to
ballet - wrestling seen it all mmm
little warrior kids getting after it
that's a book for any kid that you want
to put on the proper path of discipline
of hard work
the next book the next warrior kid book
is coming out April 28 I'll let you know
when it pops up for pre-order extreme
ownership the new edition is out it's
longer it has a little new forward in it
it's got some new pictures color
pictures by the way color oh dang
stepping it up no I don't like that Oh
like no make them black and white black
and white only that's how I roll yeah
there's also some QA on there which is
the QA that's in the new version is from
this podcast which means it's from you
listeners so thank you for the questions
and also the new version it's black and
it's flat black did you notice that it's
flat black did you notice that yeah that
makes it even better just regular black
right what's regular black glossy Oh
classy you hear that dog barking yeah
there must be somebody invading yeah the
podcast space yeah you can get that the
new version of extreme ownership right
now flat black questions from the
podcast all that also discipline equals
freedom Field Manual so this is book
it's not a normal book right we know
that it's a book dead if you give it to
somebody they don't feel like I you just
want to grab me a book they don't feel
like that yeah you think yeah because
it's not normal yeah so the publisher
knows that right so they wanted a little
tagline and they sent me some hey we
come up with some tag lines and they
they gave me this tagline sure can I
make fun of my publisher yes sounds like
I'm going to do that right now
so my publisher they say we gotta make a
little tagline you can tell your buck
and they said well you know here's our
tagline this book makes makes a great
gift from a holiday sees it something
like that right and they send me cuz cuz
I always say like hey don't be saying
stuff about my stuff without asking me
first
cuz you guys will say dumb stuff about
my cool stuff I don't like that yeah so
they said make the great holiday gift or
whatever and I said no when I thought
about it for four seconds and I wrote
them back and I said use this there is
no better gift than the gift of
discipline boom
factually there's your tagline so for
your people in your life that you don't
want to get them a stupid gift like a
necktie or a belt or something else that
they don't want or need they need this
book yeah the best gift you can give is
the gift of discipline so there you go
that's uh hey by the way people keep
asking me and I keep telling everyone
everyone wants the audio version of this
book
and they said when is it coming out it's
out its out the audio version of
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
it's out right now it's on iTunes it's
on Amazon music it's on Google Play it's
on other mp3 platforms the reason we did
that is because if you put it on audible
audible you can't pull it out his tracks
and use it for alarm or use it to spot
yourself if you get a moment a weakness
which this book is good for so that's
where you can get the audio version and
beyond the books beyond the podcast for
leadership training and execution with
your business or your team you can
contact our leadership consulting
company it's me
it's lave babban it's JP Danelle it's
Dave Burke you can email info at
Ashkelon front comm and if you have
questions for us or you have answers for
us we want to hear them both you can
communicate with us
on the interwebs on Twitter on Instagram
and on Facebook e ball echo is that echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing can to
the servicemen and women world ride
right now defending freedom thank you
for your service and for giving us the
ability to do this podcast and to the
families of those servicemen and women
that are supporting them from home thank
you for your sacrifice day to day it is
much appreciated and to the police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
other first responders thank you for
doing what you're doing which is keeping
us safe here at home and answering the
call when it comes and to everyone else
that's listening just remember that sure
you have a team you have friends and
family and co-workers and colleagues and
you have a support network and you have
people you can call and that's great but
don't count on them don't wait for them
don't assume that they are coming to the
rescue
take lead take ownership take action get
out there and get after it so until next
time this is echo and Jocko out